[Music]
every shot that kyle rittenhouse fired
in kenosha in august of 2020 was caught
on videotape that's why he's a free man
tonight it was never any doubt once you
looked at the tape that kyle written has
acted in self-defense but for political
reasons prosecutors in kenosha ignored
the evidence and they charged written
house with murder and threw him in jail
for more than 80 days then they hid
evidence from the defense
it's an appalling appalling example of
prosecutorial misconduct we asked
written house about that during our
conversation last night here's what he
said
what did you think of the prosecution
in my belief
the prosecutorial misconduct in this
case
is ridiculous they knew i was innocent
but they still decided to bring these
charges to make their name
to to have a name they wanted my head on
their shelf there's this fbi
surveillance plane may i remind you it
is illegal to survive u.s citizens but
the fbi still had a plane up
and then they tried to twist it and say
i was chasing down mr rosenbaum
never happened
and the funny thing is
we were not provided that drone footage
until october and they had it way before
and the fbi gave it to them and they
compressed that fbi drone video and gave
it to us they gave us a compressed
version of that file
so they had a dr a 4k drone
that showed the shooting of mr rosenbaum
yeah and then
do you know what handbrake is no so
assistant district attorney cross had a
software installed on his computer
called handbrake and this is just
speculation but put two and two together
we get a decompressed three
three i think it's three megabyte
file of the drone video when they have
an 11 megabyte and he has handbrake
installed on his computer
we got an extremely decompressed version
of the drone video
so i mean in a normal trial i mean
that'd be grounds for misdraw right
there i mean exactly you have to be
provided the same evidence that the
prosecution is provided by definition
and another
very very very
disgrace in this government is the fb
with the fbi drone they called the
camera operator of that drone to testify
ada binger asked us questions and then
attorney mark richards great attorney
phenomenal attorney asked his questions
he asked about the tail number the state
objected and they said he had a tui
letter
from the state attorney and we weren't
able to ask him
the the tail number so we can submit our
foia requests which are still being
appealed right now so we can get the
complete version of that night on the
drone video
he wouldn't give us the tail number
we weren't able to ask him what the tail
number was because because of the tui
letter
so that we got
the day he testified that supposedly
disappeared from attorney natalie wisco
another great attorney's email it just
completely magically disappeared from
her email because the state said they
emailed it but we never got it
so dirty
what do you think motivated binger
assistant district attorney banger is
a corrupt person who just wants to make
a name for himself and not look at the
facts
i used to be a fan of the prosecutors
not anymore i believe there's still good
prosecuting attorneys out there
but he is a prosecuting attorney that
wants to make a name for himself and
he's supposed to speak the truth and
nothing but the truth
but he decided he wanted to lie and try
to put me in prison for the rest of my
life for defending myself
i mean that must be
shocking for you as a kid
to realize the system can destroy
someone who they know doesn't deserve to
be destroyed just for political reasons
it's it's sickening because this is a
case that never had that should had
this is a case that has nothing to do
with politics but politics were brought
into it for people's own agenda
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else